Bri I wanted to ask you because I asked
Pete earlier um what is it you think
that men want from
women I think
that I think ultimately a man is Seeking
a woman
that can be
his counterpart I guess and a sense of
like they
want someone
who is going to be respectful and like
have respect for themselves like I don't
genuine I don't think that men are
seeking out women who have no
self-respect or have are like out in the
streets making a full of themselves
because that reflects your home and your
husband or your boyfriend I think they
want somebody that
is educated and I don't necessarily mean
as in like they have to have a
bachelor's or Masters or whatever I
think they just need to be able to have
some sense of um no no we're talking
about what women offer men you said that
he's got to be educated have a
bachelor's I'm talking about like what
do women need to do to attract a
guy
physically well it's generally
physically at first yeah what does a
woman need to do to attract a man yeah
like what do men
want uh big boobs skinny was waist fat
ass pretty face like okay what else
that's I
mean I feel like that conventionally
attractive that minute yeah okay um what
do you think of the notion that men want
a woman to be useful to
him like not be a burden in his life and
add some value to his life yeah that
resonate yeah absolutely what about you
P yes do you have any kids p no Bri
you've got a a daughter right yes do you
think that changes like your value in
the sexual Marketplace to men if you
bring a child to the table from a prior
relationship yes by how much like what's
the significance of that I think it
depends on the man and where they are in
their life I think mine I've been
reading the comments on this chat
um
it's I think it also depends on what the
mother is bringing like are they
bringing several children by several
different men are they still
entertaining the fathers are they still
are they expecting you to be this
child's father to take care of this
child too like MH so I think if you are
expecting that then that definitely like
brings you way
down um like this one guy this Sergeant
slack ass like he's been very very vocal
about my daughter but I don't bring up
my daughter's not on any of my dating
apps because that's just weird and I
hate when people put their children on
apps like that um I don't bring up my
what you bringing up I'm not I'm not
looking at the chat I don't watch the
chat I mean M handles that you know what
he saying M Sergeant whatever his name
is not see I've seen maybe one or two
comments but I'm SC what did he say
exactly like what was the feedback like
he said like so while she's like
sleeping with a man her daughter's in
the next roomm over and that's like
that's never been the case I don't bring
I think having a daughter is why I'm so
picky
because and why don't genuinely like
bring men into my home I don't because
this is not just my home this is my
daughter's home that's unsafe I'm not
going to bring somebody into her area
definitely not bringing anybody into her
area while she's here because I just
think that's gross and unsafe um and
then he was like so she wants somebody
and then this other guy this Colonel
Buckshot like looking
for um a paycheck looking for somebody
to raise their kid or like why are you
seeking out another man when you had one
stuff like that and that's not the case
for me I can see it being the case for
other women but I'm not looking for
somebody
to
like um buy me out of my single
motherhood like that's not something I'm
seeking I'm not introducing my daughter
to any
men what if a guy said to you Bri I dig
your Vibe enjoy dating we have fun but I
have no interested in meeting your
daughter I don't want to meet your
family I don't want to come over to your
house you're going to need to come over
to my place we date we'll have
fun um would you be able to roll at that
level or does it have to go further than
that for you like do you have to get a
further commitment where it leads to
something
more um I am not big into the like
hookup culture so if he's calling it
what it is I kudos to him because like
you know think yeah I think that would
probably fall in a category somewhere
like friends with benefits like into
dating maybe like in that space yeah I'm
not I would you know thank you for being
honest but that's not what I'm seeking
and I'm not saying that like like my
daughter's father and I have been
separated for two and a half years and
she's still I've never introduced
anybody to her because I just feel like
that's that's weird for her and probably
weird for the for the man too yeah I was
just curious from your perspective on
what your experience has been and and
like how you view your own sexual
Marketplace value as a single mom
because I think for most guys like if
it's like okay she's a single mom with
four kids from four different fathers
her value is going to be like if you had
an identical twin and you're a single
mom with four kids from four different
fathers and you had just one kid he
probably picked the twin with just the
one kid yeah interestingly I did the
survey and I'd like to hear some
feedback from the ladies on this so I pr
I presented the survey earlier this year
and it and it blew up so I provided two
options I said we've got two identical
twins they're 30 one of them has been
single her entire life she's been uh
working on cruise ships traveling the
world she shared her body with a whole
bunch of guys like her Notch counts 70
The Other Woman has been married for 10
years she has two kids and she's only
ever been with one guy which one would
you prefer to date on a longterm basis
what do you think they
chose the I I'm pretty sure they chose
the the divorce I think I saw that what
do you think P the one with kids yeah so
guys are turned off by promiscuity so
badly that they would rather invest in a
woman and another man's
kids what do you think of the notion of
a woman's Notch count being judged that
way
um I don't I don't see a a problem with
that that's
what uh that's see that's so picky
because like if you say one thing then
like oh you're anti-woman but like I
don't know I feel like if a man doesn't
want to be with somebody that's been ran
through then that's his right like he
has I don't see an issue with that what
about you
p uh if those are his standards then
like that's just him you know like maybe
some guys are okay with that and some
will not be and no it was actually it
was actually like a survey that that got
taken by close to 20,000 people and I
think it was like 98% would have chosen
the single mom with a notch count of one
and a couple of kids versus the
promiscuous girl that had slept with a
whole bunch of
dudes it's something interesting Brianna
said and P you actually mentioned this
earlier and we were chatting was like
anti-woman you know do you find that
that women generally are nice to one
another
or there's clearly some inkling of
shaming involved from women to women I
mean have you two experienced this I
mean as far as like women shaming you
for I mean you said anti- women like
what do you what kind of brought on that
comment anti-women as in like you know
you can't you're not allowed to [__]
shame you're not allowed to like oh
she's a sex worker
like at this point in our society it's
just like oh that's the same as having a
secretary job at the you know like
you're just supposed to accept that and
not judge them for that and you're not
supposed to and if any man says oh I'm
not working or I'm
not dating a sex worker then they're
like what's a sex worker is that
somebody that does like only fans or is
that we're talking about a prostitute
both all the above okay yeah would you
say that only fans like encompasses that
too P this as far as sex
work uh I would say it uh I guess so
with the modern
society um like I don't know it's just
like for example if you've traveled to
Amsterdam you go to the red light
district there's actual people in person
but now like people it's migrated to
online um so like anybody can do it from
home I guess like just and uh plus the
fact that it's online like you can use
filters like I don't know like when I
went to the red lights to trans a lot of
the women are they're they're pretty
good-looking so but from what I've heard
from like male friends and females like
not everyone and only fans is attractive
apparently I don't know I've never I've
never been on there so again not to put
down people who are who are on there or
um using those services to each their
own but um I guess that to keep up with
the constant evolving Society then yet
it counts as sex
work um the notion of promiscuity is
judged by men it seems based on that
survey result um do you as ladies like
take that into consideration when you're
dealing with guys to try to preserve
your value and minimize like your Notch
count is that's something that you've
contemplated or does it not matter yeah
but I
mean because like the same way that I
wouldn't want to be with somebody that's
been with everybody I you know like I
feel like it would
be hypocritical if I was sleeping with
every single guy that I matched with but
was setting you know the guy that I want
to be with to oh he can't have more than
three like that so I I don't partake in
hookup culture I don't
have um several
notches what about you P you mentioned
earlier that you've had a few hookups
like how does uh preserving your value
as a woman come into
play um well again I've learned through
experience like none of these were
recent um waste of 20 seconds of your
life um and uh I I don't allow any bu to
get into my pants so I have standards I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out